transgender boys who might not have
their own money to go buy tampons if
they're provided free in the bathroom
it's it's a huge plus men do not
menstruate only women menstruate now you
can call yourself whatever you want
right but trans men do menstrual
non-binary people operating is not
exclusive yes it's women no it's not yes
it is so excuse me as to why my body you
are if your Columbus homes are xx and
you're young you're menstruate correct
but what about trans men and
non-violence not putting a whole group
they're women dressed as men you are not
a man people who hate the truth are
because they see they see the truth as
hateful if you want to identify in any
way you can you're free to do so but
that does not mean that the rest of us
have to join that illusion if you're a
dude and your vagina is bleeding you've
got a problem